لا ديننا ولا عادتنا ولا تقاليدنا تسمح
للمراه العراقيه بالمشاركه في المسابقه
الخاصه باللعبه والتي ينظمها الاتحاد
الاسيوي والدولي هذا التصريح قاله رئيس
الاتحاد العراقي لبناء الاجسام والذي لقى
غضبا كبيرا من قبل النساء والراي العام من
نسوي
الاتحاد يجد ان العادات والتقاليد اسمى من
بطولاته بناء الاجسام وان دين يمنع ذلك
ايضا وان النساء الراغبات بالمشاركه في
هذه البطولات عليهن ان يشاركنا في بطولات
النسويه وباشراك كادر نسوي
لعبات كثر عبرنا عن غضبهن فبعضهن على
مجوزيتهن للمشاركه في هذه اللعبه وفي
بطولات خارجيه هذا العام لكن هذا التصريح
خذلهن ونشطات على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
وجدنا ان هذا المنع يندرج ضمن منهجيه
قائمه على التمييز لكن رئيس الاتحاد يجد
ان من حق المراه ممارسه هذه اللعبه لكن
للحصول على قواما رشيق وقوي وسليم زينب
صباح العربيه بغداد
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات